-President Trump
and his Attorney General
are turning
the Justice Department
into a political weapon
to protect Trump's friends
and punish his enemies,
and now Trump's
ex-Chief of Staff
is speaking out.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-You might remember that in
order to justify their vote
to acquit Trump
in his impeachment trial,
several Republican Senators
tried to reassure us
that impeachment would be
a teachable moment for Trump,
that he would change
his behavior,
and that he had learned
his lesson.
-Enduring an impeachment
is something
that nobody should like.
Even the president said he
didn't want that on his résumé.
I don't blame him.
So if a call like that
gets you an impeachment,
I would think he would think
twice before he did it again.
-I think that he knows now
that if he is trying
to do certain things,
whether it's ferreting
corruption there,
in Afghanistan, whatever it is,
he needs to go through
the proper channels.
-Are you confident
that the president
won't seek foreign assistance
again?
-I believe that the president
has learned from this case.
The president has been
impeached.
That's a pretty big lesson.
-You think he's learned
his lesson?
He's 73 years old and he hasn't
even learned
how to properly apply bronzer
all the way
to the top of his face.
[ Laughter ]
I mean...
[ Cheers and applause ]
For real.
Tom Hanks spent more time
putting makeup on Wilson.
And sure enough,
within days of being acquitted,
Trump began a campaign
of exacting revenge
on impeachment witnesses
and proving that he had not
learned his lesson,
as was obvious to all of us.
For example,
he vindictively fired
Lieutenant Colonel
Alexander Vindman,
a key impeachment witness
who received a Purple Heart
for his service in Iraq.
It was an on act
of petty revenge.
And, yet, Trump defended
his firing of Vindman this week
by once again insisting
that the impeachable offense
he committed, his phone call
with the president of Ukraine,
was actually perfect.
-I obviously wasn't happy
with the job he did.
First of all, he reported
a false call
that wasn't what was said
on the call.
What was said on the call
was totally appropriate.
And I call it a perfect call.
I always will call it
a perfect call.
-[ As Trump ]
It was a perfect call,
as perfect as my spray tan,
applied evenly
to every part of my face
so I definitely do not look like
an overcooked ham
with googly eyes."
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] So now that
Trump is once again
abusing his power,
the Republicans who said
he learned his lesson
are silent.
But there was one Republican
who suddenly decided to speak up
at a paid speech yesterday,
and that's Trump's former
Chief of Staff John Kelly.
Now, Kelly never spoke up
when he was Trump's
Chief of Staff
during some of Trump's worst
abuses and lowest moments.
But now that he's getting paid
to give speeches,
John Kelly seems to have
grown a conscience
and now he's suddenly
criticizing Trump.
-Former White House
Chief of Staff John Kelly
sounding off
on President Trump,
as "The Atlantic" reports,
"The retired general explained
in the clearest terms yet
his misgivings with
Trump's behavior
regarding North Korea,
immigration, and Ukraine."
Speaking last night
at Drew University,
Kelly said that,
"Lieutenant Colonel
Alexander Vindman was simply
following the training
he'd received as a soldier."
Kelly added, "We teach them,
'Don't follow an illegal order.
If you're ever given one,
you'll raise it
with whoever gives it to you
and then you tell your boss.'"
-Hey, man, I'm going to say
the same thing to you
that I say about
the president's spray tan --
"Too little, too late."
And then after those comments
went public,
Kelly was rewarded for
his belated truth telling.
The way anyone who turns
on Trump is rewarded
with a nasty personal attack
on Twitter.
Trump tweeted
"When I terminated John Kelly,
which I couldn't do fast enough,
he knew full well that he was
way over his head,
being Chief of Staff
just wasn't for him.
He came in with a bang,
went out with a whimper.
But like so many exes,
he misses the action."
I'm sorry, do you mean the word,
exes?
It's not just spelled
with the letter "X."
When you say "X," people
tend to think of the X-Men.
What X-Man would John Kelly be?
The one who waits a month
after Magneto destroys the city
and then says,
"We should have done something."
[ Laughter ]
So now Trump is in a dumb feud
with one of his former
Chiefs of Staff.
Meanwhile, we're learning
strange and new details
about his relationship
with another one
of his former Chiefs of Staff,
Reince Priebus,
and one particular
very dumb obsession
Trump had with Priebus.
Now as we all know, Donald Trump
is not a well-read man.
But it's still fascinating
to find out the things
that he's curious about.
This week, we learned
one of the strangest,
dumbest things about Trump yet
and it requires
a bit of explanation.
Priebus was Trump's
first Chief of Staff.
And he was from Wisconsin,
which you may know,
is referred to
as the Badger State.
And according to a new book
by the Trump administration
called "Sinking in the Swamp,"
Trump was obsessed with badgers
and he kept asking Priebus
questions about badgers,
even in situations where it
wasn't appropriate.
These are real highlights
from the book.
"When Reince Priebus was the
White House Chief of Staff,
President Donald Trump
repeatedly asked him
whether badgers, the state
animal of Priebus' home state
of Wisconsin,
are mean to people,
how they work,
and how aggressive they can get.
"Are they mean to people?" Trump
at least twice asked Priebus
in the opening months
of his presidency,
"or are they friendly
creatures?"
Trump also wanted to know
if the badger had a personality
or if it was boring,
what kind of damage
could a badger do to a person
with its flashy, sharp claws?
Oh, my God,
Trump is obsessed with badgers.
He's probably curious because
he can relate to the badger.
I mean, look at him. He looks
like a mama badger fending off
a hoard of coyotes.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
I mean, there's so many
questions about this.
First of all, Trump want to know
how badgers work,
like, what does he mean by work?
Does he mean,
"Do they have hearts
that pump blood
to the rest of their bodies?"
or does he mean
"Do badgers have jobs?"
[ As Trump ] So what do these
badgers do for a living?
Do they build dams like beavers?
You know, 'cause I'm --
I'm in real estate, too."
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] Seriously think
about how insane this is.
The president
of the United States
has shown more genuine curiosity
about badgers and how they work
than literally any other subject
in his portfolio.
He's 70 going on 7.
Was he asked
for environmental reasons,
or for his second-grade essay
project?
[ As Trump, monotone ]
This summer, I learned
how badgers work and if they
are mean to people.
They have personalities
and are not boring and stupid
like my ex, John Kelly."
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Normal voice ] In fact,
according to the book,
Trump showed more genuine
curiosity about badgers
than actual policy issues.
For example, just this week
he intervened directly
into the criminal case of one
of his cronies, Roger Stone,
seen here dressed like
a Bond villain,
who instead of petting a white
cat pets a Wisconsin badger.
Stone was convicted of lying
to Congress
and witness tampering to help
cover up the Russia conspiracy
as part of Robert Mueller's
investigation.
Prosecutors originally
recommended up to nine years
in jail, but then Trump
whined about how unfair it was
on Twitter,
and his Justice Department,
led by Attorney General
Bill Barr
intervened to change it to
a much more lenient sentence.
And yesterday Trump
celebrated that move
claiming no one could even
specify
what Stone was guilty of.
-I want to thank
the Justice Department
for seeing this horrible thing.
They saw the horribleness
of a nine-year sentence
for doing nothing.
Nine years for doing something
that nobody even can define
what he did.
-Just because you
can't define it,
doesn't mean nobody
can define it.
I mean, you can ask your lawyer.
he should at least
be able to look it up.
I mean, he's always
showing us his phone.
[ As Giuliani ] Boss, again,
I Googled "witness tampering,"
and it says right here,
apply ointment as necessary,
then use a cooling pad --
Oh, sorry, wrong tab.
I also Googled "what to do when
you sit on your own balls."
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] What's clear
here is that Trump and Barr
are turning the
Justice Department into a tool
for Trump's personal political
benefit.
In fact, Barr is taking
control of cases
that are of personal interest
to Trump
and has reportedly even made
himself
into Trump's personal defender.
-Barr describing
an expansive new profile
in "The New Yorker" as
attempting to maximize
executive power, and,
"Like no Attorney General
since the Watergate era,
he has acted as the president's
political sword and shield."
-That's right, Barr is now
Trump's sword and shield,
which is true metaphorically.
But you know Trump would also
love a literal sword and shield.
I'm surprised that they don't
just let him walk around
the White House with a sword
from Medieval Times
and a Burger King crown
so he can yell
[ As Trump ]
Where are you, badgers?!
Don't try to charm me with
your winning personality.
[ Normal voice ] And if it seems
to you like Barr is acting
more like Trump's
personal defense attorney
than the Attorney General of the
United States,
just remember at
his confirmation hearing
last year, Barr revealed
that he literally did interview
to become Trump's
defense attorney
during the Mueller investigation
before Trump appointed him
Attorney General.
-It was a very brief meeting
where essentially the president
wanted to know -- Yeah, he said,
"Oh, you know Bob Mueller.
How well do you know Bob
Mueller?
I told him how well I knew
Bob Mueller,
and he was interested in that,
wanted to know what I thought
about Mueller's integrity
and so forth and so on.
So he asked me
for my phone number.
I gave it to him, and I never
heard from him again.
-I mean, I know why
he never called you.
He was probably distracted by
some dumb thought about animals
that had nothing to do with
what you were talking about.
Trump was probably sitting there
while you were talking
thinking to himself,
[ As Trump ] I wonder which
animals are nice
and which ones are mean.
I bet squirrels are nice
and pigeons are mean.
Elephants are nice,
Bobcats are mean.
Groundhogs are neutral.
No one ever had a problem
with groundhogs.
Oh, and penguins are fancy
because they wear tuxedos!
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] So an imbecile
President whose only interest
in his own self-preservation is
turning the Justice Department
into a political weapon
for his own benefit,
Trump keeps digging himself
deeper and deeper,
much like Trump's great friend,
the majestic badger,
whose mating call echoes
throughout the forests
of Wisconsin.
And I imagine if Trump
were to hear that call,
he might say something like...
-They call it a perfect call.
I always will call it
a perfect call.
[ Laughter ]
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪